all right guys
bang bang caitlyn is back uh she is i
think
maybe the only person who's been on
three times now
uh thank you so much for doing this
thank you
pump it's awesome to be back absolutely
so caitlin and i
uh didn't know each other many years ago
we met uh hit it off
uh have um talked a bunch about crypto
legacy finance stuff
uh we eventually became uh investors in
avonte which is the new business that
she is
building we're super excited about that
and uh it just so happens to be directly
uh related to the latest occ decisions
so i want to bring her back on
um and before we kind of get into the
details and updates on
avanti and the occ maybe let's just talk
about the economic
uh kind of macro environment what what
have you seen in terms of how this has
played out
what has gone how you thought it would
any surprises maybe just talk to us a
little bit about kind of the macro
environment
well i guess the one thing that i would
highlight is a report that came out and
i
apologize i don't remember who wrote it
but it was awesome and i did tweet about
it so
kudos to the author uh about commercial
mortgage-backed security delinquencies
in in uh minneapolis 47 of commercial
mortgage
backed commercial mortgages are in
default
uh and it's 69 in syracuse these numbers
might not be precise but they
are staggering numbers um interestingly
new york was only at seven percent which
isn't
that much worse than sort of a steady
state
um but uh um but of course because the
dollar value of mortgage loans in new
york is so much greater that's where the
bulk of the delinquencies
in in the commercial mortgage area are
but um you really can see some some just
stunning weakness
in it from the after effect of covid and
and where is that going to show up
it's going to show up in bank balance
sheets in 2021.
um we've you know talked about this uh
back when we did the last show that you
know the bank balance sheets are
are definitely an area to watch because
right now
um the the the banks have been uh given
some
degree of flexibility they've been told
by the government just you know support
the economy
just make loans we'll deal with the
fallout later
and uh you know that's probably the
right policy decision but what it means
is there's going to be
um a lot of recapitalization necessary
once these uh delinquencies actually do
hit and uh it's interesting to see
uh the the fed uh it's multiple fed
governors now
saying look the banks need to raise more
equity capital they're not
allowed to pay dividends anymore i i
remember back uh
when the repo crisis started hitting in
spring of 2019 i started saying look the
banks are under cap the big banks are
under capitalized
we got problems here and there were some
fed governors i remember governor
brainerd dissenting
at that time in the uh in the decision
to allow the big banks to buy back stock
in the spring of 2019 and just recently
uh in the last month or so the the stock
buyback programs were halted by the fed
and now
it looks like uh the banks are probably
going to going to be
raising more equity capital but they're
not doing it right now my advice to all
the big banks is do it now
your stocks are you have recovered
really really well and this is when you
need to you know you raise you as a
publicly traded company you raise
capital when you don't need it because
when you need it
it's not going to be available for you
now the flip side is they might just
wait for the government to bail them out
because
you know every time they've needed to be
recapitalized i mean how many times a
citigroup
needed to be recapitalized in its
history i think i think three or four
so you know they maybe maybe they're the
uh
they're just waiting for the fed put so
to speak but um but the responsible
thing for them to do is to raise equity
capital the big the big banks the
community banks not so much but the big
banks
how does this change with um you know jp
morgan and others reporting like record
revenues and
and kind of really showing up uh in
their financial
uh quarterly earnings does that change
any of this conversation
or kind of how do you see that affecting
um the balance sheets and also their
need to raise capital well it is
helping for sure right because if
they're if if all those profits are
dropping to their bottom line and
they're not paying any of those
out in dividends to shareholders that's
effectively raising capital
and again you know that's that's why the
fed probably isn't putting
as much pressure on them to recapitalize
now but
look what's coming down the pike and
they know all this right um what they're
doing is doing the game theory of
you know do we really need it right they
don't no one ever wants to have to raise
equity capital it dilutes your existing
shareholders
but if you end up having to raise equity
capital you want to do it when your
stock price is at a high is at a high
price because the dilution is lower
right so um that's i'm sure every one of
them is thinking that through
what i think uh what i hope they
recognize though is that
you know governor brainerd was proven
right and uh and those
i think it's neil kashkari also um the
minneapolis fed
governor who's now said listen the banks
need to be recapitalized
yeah and you know there's dissent among
the fed and and i think
um those those that that have been
concerned about bank balance sheets are
right
they just don't want to spark a a
concern in capital markets but
you know i'm sure all the bank boards
are thinking about this uh and i just
hope that the risk people are not
um are not looking at the world uh with
rose-colored glasses
obviously the government has stepped in
printed a ton of money to try to deal
with a lot of the kovid related
um kind of more economic type issues not
just at the banks
um we see 52 million americans lost
their jobs for the last four and a half
months
uh we see pvp money going all over the
place we've had the direct stipends
uh the unemployment insurance kind of
additional uh beefing up
is going to expire at the end of july
maybe just talk a little bit about like
how do you think the federal reserve and
the u.s government has done so far in
terms of their intervention
and then how do you see that either
continuing or will it end here kind of
over the next couple of months
oh well it it's it very much depends on
how things play out but i think what
you're
you know what we're seeing now are
leading indicators of problems that are
going to be coming down the pike in you
know six to nine months with these
loan delinquencies you're starting to
see it also in you know the number of
people not paying their credit card
bills
and and rent uh as well but uh it's
coming
and so uh it but it all depends on how
badly it hits
it does look like the country's kind of
going into a soft shutdown a lot of
things are being canceled that were
pushed into the fall uh and so yeah
it's it it really just depends on how on
how deep that
that downturn is and right now we're
sitting at about call it three
trillion dollars give or take that
they've uh they've gone ahead and uh
and put out their monetary stimulus uh
i'm assuming europe the belief that
we're gonna see
trillions more or or maybe i'm incorrect
with that yeah
no i think the fed's balance sheet is is
i think the base cases that the fed's
balance sheet is 10 trillion by the time
this is over
um and and but but you got to realize
this this is where some of the austrians
miss the point
you have to understand that that what
the fed is doing right now is not
actually putting more credit into the
economy what they're doing is
backfilling for the whole
that has been that has that has appeared
because the private sector credit
creation
is declining and so what what you really
need to understand
and nobody's got the numbers to figure
this out because you really can't
measure the shadow banking system you
can't measure how much leverage there is
in the repo market
the data just doesn't exist but it's we
kind of know it's there
we definitely know it's there we just we
kind of can triangulate how big the hole
is
but they're backfilling for a whole and
this is what you know the austrians have
missed multiple times when they talk
about hyperinflation
coming now as a result of the fed
expanding its balance sheet
if the fed's expanding his balance sheet
into a true economic growth scenario
absolutely
they are adding to the total amount of
money and credit outstanding in the
economy
uh and but if they're expanding their
balance sheet when the private sector
balance sheet
is contracting what they're really doing
is just trying to offset that
contraction which is why we haven't seen
the the dollar collapse
that some folks have uh have predicted
and you know the private sector is where
the vast majority of credit creation
happens it's in the big banks and it's
in the securities markets
where especially the repo market there's
just so much credit
so much offshore credits what's called
the euro dollar market is the market for
dollars offshore
the fed doesn't directly uh uh regulate
that
uh it's it's uh it's it's foreign bank
regulators that regulate that and also
hedge funds and securities firms right
um and so there isn't anybody who's got
great numbers on that and we just don't
know how big how big that market is
um dr manmohan singh at the imf has been
following this for years
and uh and actually i he um we wrote uh
uh we worked on a chapter for his most
recent book
uh and he will be releasing that chapter
um
through a paper that hopefully is coming
out soon i've seen that seen the draft
of it and i think folks are gonna really
be interested in seeing that because
we got a couple of academics including
dr singh as well as
myself who's not an academic but a
practitioner who's been watching this
for years and talking to dr sang about
it
you know for for many years um um and
interestingly dr singh is now interested
in in
bitcoin and cbdc's and uh and and and
the like so we've we've crossed paths in
a couple of different ways and it's all
related right we're trying to figure out
what is the size of this offshore
collateral market he's the one who's
estimated
what's the size of the of the leverage
in
the shadow banking system but it really
you know he he can only estimate it
using
year-end financial statements and what
we know is there's a lot of balance
sheet window dressing that happens at
quarter-end and year-end
and so we don't know what it looks like
intra-period and even intra-day
no one knows uh and that's the piece
that's hard for the fed to figure out so
they're they're backfilling clearly
they've uh they've prevented
uh a total meltdown here um and and we
certainly
given these uh given the numbers that
are that are coming out in the economy
that
we were headed for that clearly so uh
they've definitely prevented that the
question is it's getting
it's going to get a lot trickier going
forward to try to figure out how to
how to size that the fed's balance sheet
to offset that
hole in the private sector credit
creation
how worried are you about inflation or
kind of any of the the
long-term effects of all this money
protein well see this is the thing that
inflation comes in in so many different
forms but
all the money and credit that was
created i haven't looked at the
latest z1 from the from the fed
but uh we shouldn't measure money and
credit just with the fed's balance sheet
itself
because so many assets became money-like
um especially us treasuries right and so
the fed's balance sheet
you know at at six seven trillion right
now
is is uh is is small compared to the
total amount of treasuries outstanding
what is a treasury bond it's a dollar
that pays
interest uh right so it's really not
that different they're both
effectively um full faith and credit of
the us government i know legally that's
not the case but that's how the market
treats them
right and then on top of that you've got
the big banks that have issued
um credit and then the repo market takes
those treasury bonds
and multiplies them right there are um
this is what
dr singh's work has looked at there are
three people
uh who who record that they own the very
same treasury bond that's
it's called collateral reuse and the way
the repo accounting works is that
the auditors look and say all right this
my clients got
this treasury in their brokerage account
great um so i so i confirm that it's on
their balance sheet the problem is
you've got
that happening three times you've got
three different auditors looking and
saying i've got
my client's got a treasury what you
don't realize is that behind the scenes
there's really only one treasury and
there are three people reporting it on
their financial statements right so
that's a problem because the the bank
regulators at the
top can't figure out and and by the way
chris giancarlo when he was chairman of
the cftc
talked a lot about this he still is of
course but um but he recognized this
that
it's really tough to look down into the
entire financial industry because
there's so much double and triple
counting of assets
you don't really know um how how solvent
the the industry is collectively as a
whole you you
you can't rely on the individual
financial statements because you've got
to be able to back out all that double
counting at a macro
level and we don't have the data to do
it that is part of the reason why he's
so interested
in blockchain because it allows you to
figure out who really owns
that that asset or if it is
rehabilitated or reused in any form
um how many times has it actually been
reused right now
nobody knows it's a black hole the
office of the comptroller of the
currency uh is now run by brian brooks
who was the former chief legal officer
at coinbase as you know
uh yeah and within the first 60 days of
him being on the job he issues the
clarification that came out
um this past week and essentially what
he said
is hey if you are a bank you should be
able to custody
uh the value of assets or valuable
assets for your customers that includes
everything from safety deposit boxes to
virtual vaults is kind of the language
they used
uh and that includes cryptocurrencies
being part of those valuable assets of
your of your clients and so
really issuing kind of a clarification
walk us through
kind of your understanding of like what
does this mean and what are the
ramifications
it's a big deal and it's a bigger deal
than uh
than most folks in the crypto industry
understand uh
and uh you know look the occ copied
wyoming um
his first pronouncement was looking at a
special type of payment charter
i knew that wasn't going to go anywhere
because he would really have needed
congressional authorization for that he
can't just change an interpretation of
an existing law
uh and so i figured all right that's if
that's
if that's what we're up against you know
that's uh that's not gonna change
anything
but this announcement yesterday or two
days ago now absolutely changes
everything because as of
two days ago national banks can custody
digital assets and it's just uh it is
what it is they don't need to go through
a special process unless this is a
material part of their business the way
the banking regulation works is
if it is a material part of your
business then you really have to go
through a
a procedure with your regulator where
they review what your business plan is
and the impact on the bank from a safety
and soundness perspective
but if it's one of the behemoths
literally they can be in the business
tomorrow because it's not going to be
material it's not it's not going to have
a big
impact on the bank from a safety and
soundness perspective so
um yeah we uh we've got ears to the
ground we've got a lot of people
multiple people who are inside the
circle uh i did not know this was coming
most people didn't they kept it a
a big secret but it's here and it's it's
a much bigger deal than folks realize
um in part because of some pieces that
haven't fallen into place yet
uh but uh you know um every u.s bank
is now able to custody crypto and when i
say every
some are probably thinking wait a minute
what about the state banks
only a relatively small fraction of the
number of banks in this country are
regulated by the occ
or the occ regulates national banks and
then there are 50 state regulators that
regulate state banks
at the end of the day they're not
different and there's maybe a perception
that a national bank has a
has a an advantage just because it's
national but here's
here's the difference state banks have
the exact
same master account at the federal
reserve that a national bank has they
can do the same things
and that state member banks by law can
do everything that a national bank can
do
so this is why i say every bank in the
country now
can uh can can custody digital assets as
a result of that interpretive letter
uh the interesting question is who put
that interpretive letter in
that would have had to have been one of
the national banks and uh
my my first reaction was i was assuming
it was goldman sachs goldman sachs is a
state bank they're not a national bank
so
i went uh i went i poured through the
list of national banks and by the way
we've gotten a couple calls from
national banks
uh as well because everybody has just
you know the
the not everybody realizes yet how
meaningful this is because i've seen
some uh some comments from
from some of the native crypto companies
uh that indicate to me they don't
understand what really happened yet
but they will they'll figure it out the
entire landscape in the u.s
just shifted and uh now you need a bank
license in order to be competitive that
that's that's the bottom line
i'll also point to fidelity digital put
out a tweet yesterday that indicates
they get what's going on
uh and i'll paraphrase it they said you
know congratulations to the national
banks for
for coming into this industry uh we'd be
happy to be your sub custodian
that tells you that tells you what they
know they know what's going on
and uh for fidelity to be a sub
custodian to
a national bank it's one of the big ones
so there's kind of two components here
right so a national bank
basically asked and said can you clarify
for us what their current rules are
uh the occ has clarified and said yes
you may custody
uh cryptocurrency there's the
implications on the legacy
uh kind of financial organizations and
there's an impact on the crypto
companies
let's start with the crypto companies
because i think that's kind of more cut
and dry
you previously said that now it's going
to require a bank license for people to
be competitive on the custody side
uh kind of elaborate on that a little
bit and explain it well custody and
prime brokerage uh and maybe even
exchange
um you know again it's so sort of funny
i figured out
a couple years ago when i was in wyoming
working you know spitballing on what
what should a state do to grab a
competitive advantage
we figured out that you needed to have a
bank license in order to have a
competitive
advantage here um and and and the basic
simple observation is crypto settles
very quickly
dollars settle very slowly it's not it's
not complicated
uh and if you're trying to do crypto to
fiat um
you've got some settlement problems
which which which injects
something called hair stop risk which is
airshot was a big german bank
that um that failed in the financial in
the foreign exchange market
and triggered a cascade of losses among
a lot of
a lot of banks um and and really what it
is is basically you just got settlement
risk if you don't have
it's it's like you know trading a
baseball card right both
both people hold on to the baseball card
and then they let go at the same time
that's uh that's uh uh you know you're
again kids kids tend to have the uh the
better understanding
of the way the world should work right
and the adults screwed it up
and set up these um very different
settlement cycles
for uh for for for for dollars
um and then there are a lot of wrinkles
inside of it too
uh fed wires can be reversed most folks
don't know that
you don't have settlement finality with
fedwire and then ach is a very big deal
um because you ach transactions for
consumers
they can reverse an ach transaction for
60 days beyond the settlement beyond the
statement period
and if you're at the beginning of your
statement cycle that means
your ach transaction isn't actually
settled for 90 days so this is the
reason why the crypto companies
have uh you know if you put if you if
you ach
a dollar payment into one of the crypto
exchanges
they typically don't give you access to
it right away they they want to know if
you're gonna try to take it back
um and there's a lot of ach fraud you
know we
i think most folks are aware of the
chargeback risk in credit cards but
there's chargeback risk in dollar
payments too
so those are a lot of the real world
problems and when we started working on
some of our products
we we spent a lot of time talking to
institutional traders
but also just users of of the payment
system you know keep in mind i came from
the corporate world
corporate treasury world um working with
corporate treasurers when i was on wall
street
and uh they live this pain every day
um there's a there are a lot of problems
with the fact that the us dollar
payments are delayed
so i i figured out pretty early on and
and
i haven't even talked about the
securities piece you know what does it
take to be a qualified custodian
a trust company doesn't cut it uh
because of the way the laws are written
you've got to be
a bank and a bank in one part of the
custody rule says
you can be a trust company but in the
part of the custody rule that really
matters
it says you've got it does not include a
trust company
and the definition of bank means takes
deposits and makes loans
um so you um or you've got to be a
a state chartered bank which is what
avanti is um but you've got to you've
got to fit into those categories in
order to be a true qualified custodian
and um and trust companies uh unless
they do fiduciary business which the
there's only one trust company in that
the custody's crypto that i know of
that does fiduciary business fiduciary
business means you're exercising
discretion over company assets you're
taking
fiduciary responsibility for those
assets that is not what
what typical cryptocustody is so there's
a long convoluted answer
to say the trust company licenses are
now obsolete
if a bank can custody crypto
particularly if it's one of the big guys
uh all the native crypto companies now
need to get bank licenses and you know
it's funny i was screaming this from the
mountaintop long before i started ivanti
get a bank license right president trump
told
libra get a bank license it's not like
folks weren't warned
get a bank license well it's here now
everybody's gonna have to get a bank
license and
it takes nine to twelve months to get a
bank license i i don't like the fact
that it does but it does it's an
unbelievably difficult process which is
why
probably a lot of folks looked at it in
wyoming and didn't get it started
and i'm very glad i did because you know
now i think avanti's in the pole
position we're in a really interesting
position
relative to the shift that just occurred
in the industry
absolutely and so uh with this occ
decision um that's the impact on crypto
obviously there's this massive impact on
uh the national banks and kind of
what i call legacy institutions uh many
of them just got
approval or permission uh or a green
light
okay here we go but i think a lot of
these banks are either gonna say one of
two things
one uh oh shoot we haven't been educated
on this we haven't done our work like
we got to get up to speed or two is we
actually are convinced that this is the
future this is an innovative part of
finance
we want to play here but we don't have
the talent to actually
execute on this we don't have the
institutional knowledge we don't have
the muscle memory and that expertise
and so maybe talk a little bit about how
you see like what do these banks do
they've got the green light but like
what what in practice what is the impact
well for one thing they're all
fractional reserve okay so um i
i was thinking about the the user
activated
software in the bitcoin world that
showed who really was in control of
bitcoin it wasn't the miners
it wasn't the whales it was the regular
mom and pop users of bitcoin
that's probably a misnomer because it's
probably mostly 20 somethings but
in any event you get the point it's it's
the regular users of it
um and i think the big guys don't
understand that um
just look at what what happened when the
big when when cboe and cme came in it
went back
came in by the way both times bitcoin's
price went down
why because the big guys are fractional
reserved right they're not set up
to to to be 100 reserved they're not set
up
that they you know their systems
inherently rehypothecate assets right
they're they're going to rehabilitate
bitcoin right and
and one of the interesting things that
is going to come out of this
is do they really understand that and do
they uh
you know what kind of risk um
protections are they going to put into
their systems
to ensure that they don't blow up this
literally could blow them up
um and so they they they really need to
be careful and i'm sure the regulators
understand that
um one of the other pieces is the the
basic commercial law clarifications
related to digital assets have not been
made in
any state but wyoming so and and they
they they understand that they recognize
that we actually uh you know put some
phone calls
through uh through through folks into
the regulators and one of the pieces of
feedback was we understand that there's
legal risk in this because
the digital assets fall through the
cracks in
existing commercial laws in the united
states they don't fit in the existing
categories that's what wyoming did we
mapped them
to existing categories so you've got
statutory protection in wyoming that you
don't have
in any of the other states um and and
and it hasn't mattered that much
because intermediary to intermediary
there is statutory protection
but citing one of nick carter's studies
only 20 to 25 percent
of bitcoin and ether are estimated to be
held by intermediaries
so the vast majority of digital assets
are actually held by individuals and
they're the ones
when you have an individual involved in
a crypto trade that's not clearly
legally enforceable
and the responsible attorneys um one of
the
one of the stable coins uh actually
warns this
that it's not clear that your
transaction is legally enforceable
anywhere in the world
because it's not clear where it fits
within existing commercial law
i don't mean to call them out because i
think what they're doing is responsibly
warning people right so with that
in mind how headlong do you think the
banks are
are going to be going into this industry
and and how comfortable do you think
the examiners of the banks who
understand this
are going to be with them going into it
in a in a in a very big way
um but then then to come back around to
to answer where i think your question is
going
this is complicated stuff right and and
you've got to have
people who know what the heck they're
doing um and
it was interesting how backed came out
and they were going to be you know
in bitcoin right away right and they
were they were um they made some very
big claims
uh two years ago i think it was two
years ago two summers ago when that came
out
and then guess what they didn't open for
more than a year later
it all got delayed delayed delayed and a
lot of that was because i think they got
in it and figured out
oh boy this isn't what we thought it was
it doesn't actually um
map very well to our existing businesses
and uh our skill sets are
are really not ready for this and they
went out and hired bitcoin people so now
let's let's uh let's fast forward to
whoever this bank is and those national
banks that now are scrambling and they
are
um uh there is a there are only
a handful of engineers in the world who
know how to do this right and
uh it's yeah and and i think the skill
set having been inside one of the big
behemoth banks
and worked on their blockchain um
working group
with the cto of the company i i will say
that the skill set
is just different um from a from an
engineering perspective there's a
culture difference massive culture
difference but the skill set's really
different too
um and and the best way that i explain
it is
the the organization of the traditional
financial services industry is very
designed
towards towards delayed net settlement
and you've got all these
layers of intermediaries you settle with
each other and
everybody owns their own data and so
you're batching you're still really
batching transactions
um not in the old old sense but but you
know you're not getting
legal subtle legal final settlement
until after
well it can be days but the banks
themselves you know settle with the fed
after hours
every night but they're each batching so
they're net settling on a delayed basis
against each other every day
um and so that's that's a very that's
the architecture
of traditional financial services and
they use you know traditional
centralized
sql type databases they they they have
very very very very very strong
firewalls and then once you
get if a bad actor gets inside the
firewall
they get everything because it's
unencrypted why does it need to be
unencrypted you're dealing with eight
you know
hft trading um customers
uh it's just their their architecture is
not designed
for decentralization so what i just
described
is you know this layered delayed net
settlement system with centralization
and everybody owns their data
now we're going to decentralization no
layers whatsoever
really fast settlement cycles and
everybody shares their data
it's a totally different skill set and
really a totally different mindset
um and and uh and then again when you
start
putting bitcoin into the collateral pool
and all of a sudden repo accounting
comes in and you start you start
thinking you actually own
the bitcoin that's on your financial
statements because it's in in iou form
and you know your auditors look and say
yeah i've got that iou
but maybe you really don't own it
because maybe that bitcoin got
rehypothecated
at least with bitcoin you're going to be
able to have a better sense than with
traditional securities
how we hypothecated that bitcoin was but
um
but it's still a danger right so you
there's there's just a lot that the
traditional financial
institutions uh either well they need to
understand
it i don't know if they do yet we'll see
who you know when this when this big guy
comes out
and starts getting into into digital
assets we'll see if they really
understand it
i think if they had been picking off uh
the right
engineers all along that that we would
have known that it's kind of like with
the the asic miners
you know if a big government were coming
after bitcoin the asic miners would
suddenly start
disappearing from the market the asic
you know the the the chips
uh because they're so specialized it's
just like with the engineers here
they're so specialized
that if the engineers started
disappearing from the job market and
and appeared in uh suddenly appeared in
one place i think we kind of know about
that right we kind of knew about square
before
before it happened we don't know about
that with this with this uh big bank
whoever they are
so well it's going to be fun grab the
popcorn and and it feels like
um this is definitely going to be a
builder buy analysis by
you know whatever bank put in the
request but also all of their
competitors as well
and i get the feeling that you're on the
same side as i am which is there's gonna
be a lot more
buying than building because of that
yeah sorry to talk over you that is
exactly
what the point we're vehemently agreeing
with each other yeah because of all the
reasons i just laid out they're gonna
have to buy um and you know here's where
the culture difference
starts to become a really interesting
um issue a lot of the crypto companies
were started by natively crypto people
who've never worked in the financial
services industry a few of them have for
sure so they have some sense but they've
also got
huge teams of people who are kind of
anti-bank right
um and now if a big bank comes in and
buys them you know
we'll see how this whole thing plays out
again you know grab the popcorn it's
it's going to be fascinating but um but
i i i guarantee
i i know firsthand there's just a lot of
phone calls being made there's a lot of
activity happening
right now and i also know are some
native crypto companies who don't yet
understand the magnitude of the
landscape
shift that just happened they will
figure it out in in the next
few weeks as as the pieces fall into
place there's a reason why i've always
said long bitcoin short the bankers
you know it's funny i was thinking about
that because obviously you're invested
in avonte right i mean
it's like everything in life nothing's
quite black and white like that
and uh you know some folks on twitter
were uh we're trolling you for
for that statement that the bank rapper
around traditional crypto traditional
misnomer the bank raptor
rapper around crypto businesses makes
perfect sense
the traditional bankers coming into
crypto that's where you
that that's where you know we've got a
bit of a risk so
um so we want the the traditional crypto
companies to be able to compete
in the us and they need a bank rapper to
do it um the trick is
to my knowledge i i mean it's possible
coinbase obviously brian brooks came
from coinbase
it's possible coinbase already has a
bank application in
and uh but you know it's thousands of
hours of work it and it's typically nine
to 12 months
to to to to get your your charter
approved
um and even if you go out and buy an
existing bank you're still gonna have to
go through that same
process it's actually even a longer
process if you buy an existing bank
because
you've got a change in control right and
so frankly i think what will
end up happening is that the banks will
buy these companies because
it doesn't trigger that whole change of
change and control process
but the culture clash is going to be
fascinating there's just going to be a
massive upheaval in the landscape of the
crypto industry and like i said in the
tweet storm yesterday the vc funds
are the biggest winners and i think the
consumers the crypto consumers are also
really big winners too as you know
have been pretty critical of of the
terms and conditions that
the existing crypto providers have been
sharing um
have been offering their customers and
uh the big banks
are are definitely and the regulators
are not gonna let
one-sided terms and conditions um be
be out there in the marketplace so the
consumers the
regular folks who who trade with
with crypto companies are going to be
winners too and that's another one of
the reasons why
native crypto companies who don't have a
bank license are
are are gonna have to do something here
because
they're just gonna get elbowed out by
the bank license and
bank licensed companies and they're also
uh you know by offering more respectful
terms and conditions that are not so
one-sided to themselves
um again you know markets work that the
the institutions are going to trade with
the with the banks that have
better terms and you know more
respectful terms and conditions um
yeah you're nailing the reason why i
don't say long bitcoin short the banks
as they short the bankers right because
because the
the ethos is different right in terms of
i actually think there's going to be an
entire
um kind of coalition or uh
you know demographic of people who say
hey look i need to use the bank
uh legal structure and that rapper as
you talked about but we just want to do
it a different way right and obviously
you guys are
leading the charge there um give us an
update in terms of uh wyoming and avanti
kind of
what is transpired so last time we
talked you hadn't raised uh money yet
uh there's a lot that's gone on kind of
just walk us through what uh what you've
been up to
well i'll point to the public
announcements we've made on our website
um like i said again you know it takes
nine to twelve months to get a bank
license we're gonna be
uh we're gonna be on that short end
started in january
and uh we should we should have it in
october i didn't actually have a bank
application in at that time but we were
doing a lot i was when it was just me
doing a lot of work with the regulators
of
um we were going down the path by the
way of of the abbott
uh um uh proposal i was working with
the regulators on that um that's been in
process
since january but uh but uh it does take
time for sure to get
um to get a bank license and uh so when
we last talked i think it was right
after
the markets were exploding with covid
and we were laying out that from a macro
perspective what was going on
at that point we didn't have our bank uh
charter application in
uh we do have to have the bank oh don't
here
my light just fell okay sorry that's
funny um
my uh the the bank charter application
uh is uh
it's funny it's a new gig i just a new
setup i just got and it's not very
stable obviously i need to worry i need
to figure out figure that out
uh anyway uh that's funny um
we have our charter application and we
raised we raised money and uh
uh like i announced yesterday the um the
charter application process has been
accelerated we
i didn't want to announce last uh last
week uh but you knew as
an investor in ivanti uh that that we
actually got that official letter that
our application has been accepted
what does that mean it doesn't mean that
we're chartered not at all so we still
have some risk that we're not going to
be able to get chartered
what it means is that all of the major
legal issues
and operational issues and and
examination issues that bank examiners
care about we've passed all those
hurdles
and there's just been extensive
extensive literally when i say thousands
of hours we're trying to estimate it
and i was like you know man i don't even
know how to estimate it because we've
been burning midnight oil there was one
one point where we that the regulators
asked us to get something in
faster than we planned and for literally
24
7 for about 10 days somebody in avonte
was
working um it was nuts and
the team has just been absolutely
amazing we just because we're doing this
we're just the whole thing has been a
sprint and we realize now the value of
what we've done because
uh we've we've got that uh bank charter
application that's been accepted which
is
in this environment is golden given that
the world is going to be shifting to
banks and so as this occurs like you've
got two kind of key pieces right so
you've got the bank charter application
that's in
uh that looks like that's going to get
granted on the on the shorter end of
that 9 to 12 months
that seems pretty clear-cut i saw a
couple of questions online just like
who is going to be the target customer
there is that uh consumers and retail is
that institutions
how do you think about um kind of the
breakdown of the customer base
yeah we're definitely going after
institutions uh that's my background
and and um that's that's where i think
the the especially being a bank it's
just so hard to be a bank that serves
consumers trust me i've been
deep in the weeds of all those decisions
we've we made
the decision to go ahead and serve high
net worth individuals because
some of the crazy regulation that we
would face if we served
uh regular consumers uh is is not
something we have to take on
the complexity involved with that is
staggering and
uh just the magnitude of regulation
involved in in consume
serving consumers as a bank is is just
really stunning there's just so
there's so much compliance cost in in
serving a bank and by the way it it it
makes me re
really take my hat off to uh to
signature to silvergate especially
because they they were first and then
signature and metropolitan
uh man they took on a lot of of risk in
serving this industry and
um boy are they ahead too now that uh
now given what's happened um i it's
going to be interesting to see how how
the landscape shifts vis-a-vis them
because they've got
the policies and procedures in place
they've been through the regulatory
ringer
on on serving crypto and now they can
custody crypto they don't
i know in silvergate's case it was
publicly disclosed that they were
applying for a new york
trust company subsidiary so that they
could custody crypto
which you may think is kind of strange
because banks have trust powers why
weren't they doing it within the bank
well it's because of the regulatory
issues that were
until two days ago in place um and
and now they can so godspeed um
they they they paid their dues and uh
and now they get to ride that wave uh
yesterday in the announcement that you
made uh you mentioned
avid i know that there's um a lot of uh
kind of things you can't talk about
but uh you mentioned it and so maybe
kind of just whatever you can elaborate
on there
uh what what exactly is that and kind of
what's the thought process
well it's uh so so i'll step back by
saying
my whole career i've started three
businesses within big banks so i know
what it takes to do that
and uh the last business actually all of
the businesses i started were in some
way
designed to solve problems that
regulation created
and do it by figuring out how to use a
different set of regulations and meld
the two you know find the find the way
to
work on a compliant basis in between the
two regulations and so
an example was that the large-scale
pension businesses i
what i all of these business ideas are
very simple it's just
and frankly great business ideas are
always very simple uh
what i realized is that a pension and an
annuity are the same thing economically
it's just that they're regulated in very
different ways
and so i figured out how to take
corporate pension obligations and get
them
restructured in a way that life
insurance companies could provide
as an annuity and do it in a way that
was a win-win-win for everybody a win
for
for the pensioners because they got a
fully funded pension
with a much better uh
a much more solvent counterparty they we
did them all in separate accounts that
are legally segregated on the balance
sheets of the insurance companies
um but because of the efficiencies
that that we were able to eke out uh
the uh there there were it's it's like
an
all stock m a deal where both stocks go
up
because you have real efficiencies that
are that accrue to both sides
and you just have to figure out which
efficiencies go to which counterparty
so we were playing um in in i figured
out a way to have win-win-win
business business opportunity and it was
a product structure that took
an unbelievable amount of detailed
structure
and what i will say here when i said i
don't think that avid will end up with a
counterpart
there is there are a couple of very
particular reasons why
that i won't lay out um but we've uh
this this is very analogous to to
what i've done in those other businesses
um really
deep detailed understanding of
of of regulation it's something that
only a bank
can do a broker dealer can't do it
you've got to have a bank license to do
this
and it's something that can only be done
because of a legal precedent in a
certain part of the country
and you know you've got to have an
engineering team to to do it
and then structure it in a way that uh
that is a cash equivalent
it's it there is no no analogy to this
and oh by the way you've got to be in a
jurisdiction where the commercial law is
clear and you've got to
also um be a 100 reserve bank right so
to be able to pull something like this
off is uh it's a very narrow
um universe but uh we've been working
with we haven't announced this yet but
we've been working with uh the retired
treasurer of a very very very large
fortune 10 company and uh he's been
helping us
and again you know i want to solve
problems in the as much in the crypto
world as as in the the end user world
um the buy side and businesses are the
users of the
of the payment system and essentially
corporate treasurers are
uh are are not as well known as hedge
fund managers because you don't see them
talking about
the state of the financial market on
cnbc but they actually control
a lot more flow than than big
institutional investors and so and they
live this
these the issues of the payment system
and how
uh their the payments are delayed um i i
did on my on my website
uh published an interview with the cfo
of seagate technology
now almost four years ago he's no longer
there um
but he uh he talked about um one of the
challenges that they had was that they
would get um
you know multi-hundred million dollar
vendor payment and they
and they'd get it um once a quarter and
it was due
on a particular date and they always got
it the next day
and that one day of of delay
in payment the the the customer always
blamed it on the payment system
that one day delay and payment for for
the working capital that a company had
to finance for that one day
multi-hundred million dollar delay in
payment was staggering
in cost and so i i think that businesses
if they have the ability to use
real-time payments
um or or certainly same-day payments
um give them a choice let's let them do
it uh and
i will say also one of the interesting
things about the way we structured this
is it's not a competitor to the existing
payment systems the fed has got fed now
um that it that is coming this actually
complements fed now
it doesn't replace it and so um this is
a this is a really
fed now is going to speed up settlement
cycle so it's definitely going to attack
the problem i just i just talked about
but if you're a trader and you want your
trade to settle fast so you don't have
counterparty risk or you don't have
capital tied up in an unsettled trade
then you like something like this if you
are a corporate treasurer who's got a
payment that you really really need to
be able to track
and not get lost in the system you
really really really need to be able to
know that it got to the right place at
the right time
then this is going to help you so that's
what we're working on it's big stuff
i am obviously a huge fan so much so
that we invested um
you've done a fantastic job laying out
kind of occ's decision
uh and avanti and kind of how that
decision will affect
uh both the crypto companies and legacy
uh institutions
one of the things that uh i think is not
yet being talked
about a lot in the crypto community uh
and also
um kind of into the banking world is
we're in an election year
and so obviously there's a very specific
kind of
posturing that comes from a
republican-led presidential
administration who cares who the actual
president is but just there are certain
things that come from a republican
led one versus a democratic one if there
was a
shift back to a democrat-led
administration
do you foresee uh impact whether
positive or negative on any of this or
do you feel like this somewhat is
insulated from kind of who is actually
in control of the presidential uh office
no it's definitely not insulated um and
keep in mind brian brooks who's done a
lot of great
things for for for crypto and just
literally
even even if nothing ever ends up coming
of this he certainly helped mainstream
it
um but needless to say uh um he's a
political appointee he was actually he's
the acting controller he's not even been
confirmed as controller so one of two
things is going to happen either
either he leaves in january if biden
wins or he gets another four years and
then
presumably he'll be formally nominated
for the confirmation process
but think about that right you've got a
whole staff of career people
and now an acting commissioner comes in
and
uh definitely shakes things up as you
can imagine there there are that's a
difficult
position for him to be in but but the
career people are the ones that have the
continuity and they're also the ones on
the ground who are examining the banks
so um that's going to be interesting to
see
you know is this just coming from the
top from somebody who's temporarily in
their job and it doesn't
it's more pr than substance or is this
real
and uh we just have to watch watch this
play out but there's no question
that it is um that it does matter now to
your point will
biden biden administration be any
different the trump administration has
been schizophrenic on this right you you
have trump himself attacked bitcoin
last summer you had menuchen uh
essentially say
hell no right and now here we've had
this very big u-turn
from the bank regulators in the united
states so
um and by the way the head of the fdic
is also a political appointee the only
one that's somewhat insulated from it
just because of the different
cycles and and and appointee um cycles
and
and governance is the fed the fed's
definitely more insulated than the from
the political process than the occ and
the fdic are
but there was a big u-turn that just
happened so i don't i don't think that
the biden administration to come back
and answer your actual question
is is going to be any different there
are going to be folks in the biden
administration who hate this
and they're going to be folks in the
biden administration who love this so
is there a world where um you know trump
does not get reelected there's a
biden-led administration
uh brian brooks is out as kind of the
controller of the currency
and there's actually a reversal of this
clarification or
kind of could we go backwards in some
way well i mean having an interpretive
letter come out for a particular bank
it's kind of like an sec
no action letter they don't reverse
those so
um so yeah no this is this is this is
this is for sure
um but by putting an interpretive letter
out
um this is this is going to stick but
it is uh it is the case that it may get
cut back so one of the things that
hasn't happened here we haven't talked
about this yet
um is is the rules uh there are no rules
there is no supervisory manual
the the the bank regulators have no idea
how to supervise this
and banks go through regular
examinations that's one of the
differences between a bank and a trust
company
they go through regular examinations the
trust companies i happen to know that
most of the dress companies in in the
crypto industry have not been examined
by their regulators yet they don't know
what they're
if they ever have a regulatory exam they
don't they don't really understand the
magnitude of what that's going to be
like it's it's a it's a lot more
invasive than an audit um but part of
the reason i think that some states
like nevada and south dakota haven't
haven't examined
their um their their trust companies new
york has
but part of the reason they haven't
examined them is there's no supervisory
manual they don't know what they're
examining
so um i happen to know that literally
there is exactly
one supervisory manual out there in the
united states and it's in wyoming
so ultimately the regulators share
things with each other that you know the
wyoming supervisory manual is
uh that the finishing touches are being
put on it right now
and they will end up sharing that
through through different regulatory
means
so that's going to accelerate things but
they don't have it now and then you've
got you've also got the point of
training right the wyoming folks have
been working on this for two years
there are people who really are deep
into crypto and have been working with
the
applicants and advisors in crypto for
years now
um and and that doesn't exist at the occ
so
i think that um this is just this
definitely going to take more time
and and and even though the interpretive
letter is out there that does not mean
that the examiners are going to
let this through um very quickly and i
think they may take their time and
and frankly time is on the examiner's
side precisely because
the commercial laws are not clear i
should have mentioned earlier that there
is a process that will clarify
commercial laws the uniform law
commission
a group that wyoming got into a bit of a
tussle with because they were criticized
critical of us for jumping out in front
um they
they have a working group that that has
been now underway for a year
and they're looking at revising the
commercial code for
digital transactions of all types
including including virtual currencies
and it's coming but that's going to be a
probably a three-year process
at least um and for example i happen to
know in the state of new york there's
one part of
of the uniform commercial code where new
york never
adopted the uh the update that was put
out more than 20 years ago so sometimes
it takes 20 years for these things to
get through
um the the state legislatures they've
got to go through all 50 state
legislatures this isn't something that
washington d.c
can just by fiat you know say i'm
changing things and every state has to
follow it
it commercialized state law and so every
state has to update it and so this is a
long process and
and again the regulators are going to be
looking at that saying how do i know
that i've got legal enforceability of
these contracts
you are a bank you have to operate in a
safe and sound manner you're not allowed
to take this risk
and unfortunately i will say though the
impact of what i just said
is that the really really really big
banks are the ones that are going to be
able to do this
and the regulators will let them do it
because it's not going to
have an impact on their safety and
soundness of their bank
i will say though when i talked about
the blow up risk previously the reason
why there's blow up risk here is there's
no lender of last resort in bitcoin
nobody's creating any more of it okay um
and so if if they don't understand that
and they don't get the
the controls in place to be sure that
that the bitcoin is not being
rehabilitated
and it's not just an accounting illusion
that they
that the that you've got the bitcoin
you've got to actually have the bitcoin
um then you know that then they're in
for some trouble
and again the regulators i think are
probably going to do that wyoming's
statute requires proof of reserves as
part of the audit process
can you imagine if the banks had to do
proof of reserves on their securities
book
um they couldn't because they you know
number one it's not provable and number
two the securities don't exist we all
know there's so much collateral reuse
um that somebody's gonna come up short
in the game of musical chairs but in the
in bitcoin you can't play that game
there is no
more bitcoin that's going to be created
and so all these
issues these very very real hurdles
are gonna they're gonna be there and the
bank regulators know it
and they're they're not gonna make it
easy um again i started three
three businesses inside big banks i
dealt with regulators they're not gonna
let the big banks
off the hook very easily but by the same
token though they're not going to put
them
through the enormous upfront pain that a
small bank that's taking this on or a de
novo bank like avanti that's taking this
on
is going to have to go through and we've
gone through that pain already
it feels like the uh there's a tectonic
shift
in uh in kind of the finance world
legacy world
uh and crypto is at the center of it and
kind of bitcoin as an
asset uh is growing up it's maturing um
the last question i have for you is just
talk a little bit about uh maybe the
downsides to the financialization of
bitcoin right
you're talking a lot about kind of how
this will change the banking
infrastructure and and business model
what does this do to bitcoin
in kind of the long term yeah it's the
same thing when i wrote the forbes
pieces a couple years ago about
backed getting into it um you know
bitcoin is going to get financialized
it's going to get rehypothecated
um it it you know part of some folks
were were scratching their heads why did
bitcoin's price not go up
it's for the same reason that bitcoin's
price actually went
down um when backed got announced um and
when the futures
companies entering the space got
announced because this is gonna they're
gonna financialize it
and the the misnomer about
financialization
is that it actually helps price it
actually suppresses price
yes you get more liquidity that's that's
a positive uh
yes you're going to have uh you know a
new 10 ton gorilla
in the industry it seems um and and you
know
some some might say that's positive some
might say that's not they're going to be
bringing
more liquidity no doubt um but they're
also going to be
going to be doing the the same tricks
that wall street does
because they can't avoid it that's the
way their systems are designed
and as a result bitcoin is going to get
financialized
even more and that's not good for
bitcoin ultimately long term
at the end of the day though again the
the real users control it
um and and so i'm not worried about
bitcoin one bit
if they want to come in and suppress the
price i'll just buy more
but uh you got to realize that um
that that that the the game just changed
right
with the 10-ton gorilla coming in and
and and i'll and i'll close by saying
you know
a lot of your listeners are probably
just lis just hearing all this and
and it's like nails on a chalkboard to
them because
it's a regulatory game and what am you
know bitcoin wasn't supposed to be
involving banks and
um and and why are we talking about
regulation we're trying to decentralize
things the the reality is that um
you're right bitcoins bitcoins
decentralized but there are a lot of
there's a lot of money out there in the
universe that needs to
uh that has to be held by third parties
about eighty percent of the financial
market is in institutional hands that
are
that are subject to the requirement that
a
third-party custodian be involved and
because of that the operational systems
for those that even don't have that
requirement
they all just effectively do it they
don't custody their own assets they they
hire state street or bank of new york to
do it right
um and then the manager manages them but
by law and by tradition and by
operational real-world constraint that's
the way the world works and so if we're
going to have that big money coming in
uh we're going to have to find ways to
do
to provide those services in a way that
doesn't violate the the bitcoin ethos
and and uh maybe last statement if a
really big bank did get
the u-turn in washington dc done with
brian brooks's help
um what does that say right uh
again i think the uasf analogy is a
really good one
um and i and and for avanti you know in
the position that we're in yeah the fed
master account
is the same fed master account the bank
has the big bank has right
so as a small state bank um we're not
disadvantaged relative to them
it's just that maybe they they're as
patrick bernie used to say they've got
the regulators on speed dial
um and uh and as a small bank uh
certainly in dc
we don't so there's a david and goliath
thing about to go on
i know who the who the uh the
traditional crypto industry is going to
support
uh the one that actually uh uh really
truly holds their ethos
um i know but i also know who the
speculators are
are likely to support they're they're
going to support both because they want
to see
um more liquidity and it's all to them
you know
they've got to be mercenaries it's all
about best price it's all about who's
giving them liquidity
uh and if and if the big bank comes in
and starts
lending and rehypothecating you know
frankly the hedge funds that are in this
space are are gonna do business with
them
uh but beware because at the end of the
day
they will never control bitcoin uh the
the end users control bitcoin
and uh and so i'm not worried about it
but
boy it is going to it's a massive shift
of the landscape i think folks who are
listening to this podcast are going to
get that sense
now that even if they don't um yet
and they don't believe you and me they
will see it in the next few weeks
caitlin i could talk to you literally
forever about this stuff
uh thank you so much for taking the time
to do this uh you have one of the best
commands i think in terms of all the
intricacies and nuances of it
where can we send people to uh follow
you or learn more about avanti and stay
updated on all the progress you guys
make
yeah uh we will continue to put press
releases out at avontebank.com
uh and then obviously on twitter and
linkedin i also have a website
caitlin.long.com but i haven't had time
to update it so apologies that it looks
kind of crappy right now
we'll get it we'll get it fixed
eventually but i got bigger fish to fry
right now
so awesome to talk to you again thanks
pomp absolutely we'll have to do this
again and keep going the rest of us
are cheering you on thank you so much i
appreciate it